The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, so
let's get started.
A recap.
You should be all pleased
that you have learned a lot.
We covered the
quantum, solid state,
and the statistical physics in--
this is my lecture 11.
And so what we learned, first,
the quantum and the solid state
gives us the energy levels
and the energy state--
what is the quantum state.
And the statistics give us at
the equilibrium, which quantum
state, how many particles--
phonons, electrons, photons.
And going back to counting
the state degeneratively,
we get the density of state.
So at a certain energy
level per unit energy
interval or per unit,
we factor how many
quantum states we have.
So with that, you
can do the counting.
And this is a F times
D gives me number
of particles near the
energy per energy interval.
If you integrate,
that should give you
the total number of particles--
electrons, phonons, photons.
Or, if you multiply by
the energy of a particle,
that gives you the energy.
Or, if you multiply
by charge, it'll
give you the charge density.
If you multiply by the momentum,
it gives you momentum, right?
So with that, you can
start doing, for example,
the energy stored,
specific heat, et cetera.
And then we said that, at
the end of last lecture,
we're moving on to
look at the transport.
And the first idea
is we look at is,
if I want to find out how much
energy is going from 0.1 to 0.2
into different space, and
what I'm going to find out
is, what's the transmittance?
So if I have a
particle or wave, now I
don't know how to call it.
It's particle-wave duality.
And say if I have a carrier,
electron, phonon, photon
launching from point 1, and
the transmittance is how much,
how many of them will
reach point two, right?
That will give me the fraction.
And then say, if I
know the velocity,
then I know the flux
from 0.1 to 0.2, which
is the velocity in that
direction, transmittance,
and if I want to find the
energy flux, that's per, say,
this is how much energy I
have starting from that point,
right?
So this is where we're going.
In the common
chapter, we're going
to focus on using the
wave picture to deal
with this transmittance.
And then, if I want to find
the left flux, if you recall,
in chapter 1, we
derived Fourier law.
We say from 1 to 2
and minus 2 to what?
The difference can
be the left flux.
So what we're emphasizing so
far is how to do the counting.
And our focus in this chapter is
talking about the wave picture,
right?
We've been using the web
and Schrodinger's equation
for atoms, electrons,
and all our wave picture.
And why we have
to look at a wave?
And this is important if
I deal with the interface.
Because as I mentioned
before, ideal interface
is zero thickness, right?
It's a comparative wavelength.
If that's a very small
compared to wavelengths,
then I should use
the wave picture.
And so here is the
magnitude, order of magnitude
of this wavelength, right?
Blackbody radiation.
When this displacement or, say,
wavelength times temperature
is about 3,000 micron Kelvin,
so at room temperature,
that's 10 micron.
It's a very large distance,
10 microns, compared
to a zero-thickness interface.
So if I have a flat
interface, I need
to consider the wave optics,
even for thermal radiation.
And the electrons, here
are two different pictures.
If I look at the
electrons in metal,
the Fermi level is within the
band, and the corresponding
to this Fermi level, those
are the electrons that moves.
Near Fermi level are the
electrons that move, right?
And the corresponding wavelength
is within the bands, right?
This is zero, this is
pi over a, [INAUDIBLE]..
So if it's half, that's a
wavelength is about 2a, OK?
Or, say, of the order of
a few lattice constants,
that's the electron
wavelength in metal there.
And if I look at
the semiconductors,
if I say this is a valence
band, and most of the electrons
is at bottom of the valence
band, so that's a layer k
equals 0.
And those wave electronics could
have very long wavelengths.
And in fact, say,
in the last lecture,
we talked about the
deBroglie wavelengths.
So that's a thermal--
if I have a thermal energy,
kT, of the, say, average energy
kT of the electron,
kinetic energy,
what's the corresponding
wavelength?
That's the deBroglie
wavelength, right?
So the last lecture, we got
the h squared and 2 pi m k BT.
So if I substitute my numbers,
this is the H is 6.6 10
to the minus 34 jar second.
This is the h.
And in the denominator,
I have 2 pi.
If I think about electron mass,
9.1, 10 to the minus 31, and kb
is 1.38 10 to the minus
23, and 300 Kelvin.
Square root.
You go to do that,
you get this number.
I get about 40 angstrom.
So it gives you the
average wavelengths
of those electrons
with that energy, kt,
near the bottom of
the conduction band.
So again, this is like--
40 angstrom seems awfully small.
But we said before, the sharp
interface is zero sickness,
and in fact, you can deposit the
layers almost atomically flat.
So again, say if
we're in those cases,
you should consider the wave
reflection, transmission, just
as optical waves.
And phonons, this is the
dispersion we learned before,
a typical one.
And of course, at the zone
boundary, the wavelength is 2a.
And it goes for a
very long wavelength,
so this is the sound waves.
If you have a solid, they
lock it, you'll hear it.
It's a very long
wavelengths at the zone
center to the whole just 2a, in
between the lattice constant.
And if you do your--
like a black-body for phonon,
you do your density of states,
you remember when we do
black-body radiation,
we do energy of a photon
times dense substrates
times the Bose-Einstein
distribution.
That's how we get
black-body radiation.
And then you do the
same for phonon.
You see, it's similar to a
black-body, this spectrum,
except that you are cut off.
You have cut off
wavelengths because it's
unlike electromagnetic
wave in free space.
That one goes very small.
So the 2a lattice constant.
So overall, it's
good if we start
with thinking when I
calculate the transmission,
next I will consider
one single interface.
If I have one, two.
And I have those waves.
This could be electron
wave, could be photon wave,
and could be phonon wave,
comes to the interface,
and they will be
reflected, and they also
could be transmitting
across the interface.
How much-- how I can calculate
how much is reflected
with how much transmitted?
So that's my first
order of business.
And that will give
me the transmission
from one side of the
interface to the other side
of the interface.
And of course, I
could have layers
or I could have many layers.
I'm considering really a planar
geometry, make it 1D problem.
Simpler.
So in this case,
1 and 2 and 3 all
have multi layers, coating,
using optical coatings.
How I will calculate the
transmission and reflection?
And turns out,
the waves are very
similar whether it's an
electron wave or phonon wave
or electromagnetic wave.
You'll see the behavior are very
similar although at the quantum
level, we know that electron,
phonon, photons are different.
But the general way behave
in terms of interference,
in terms diffraction, in terms
of tunneling, all of those
exist for all waves.
And there are different
technologies developed
based on this phenomenon.
So let's look at--
start with a plane wave
and then one interface.
Let's just consider the
simplest plane wave.
And then the reflection
at the interface.
You can see here I'm
not even distinguishing
whether it's electron,
electromagnetic,
although my detailed
derivation will
have the right style with
different wave equations.
And in this case, I want to
actually start with a quantum
wave, or electron.
And that's because
that's the simplest.
Electron, if you think
about Schrodinger's equation
in a certain sense, it's
simple because of scalar.
The wave function is scalar.
It's a lot of vector.
When I go to acoustic waves,
the lattice vibration,
there are three polarizing, two
transfers, one longitudinal.
Electromagnetic wave
is a vector wave.
The electrical field is
perpendicular to the direction
of propagation.
There are two polarization.
So I will start with
the simplest electron
wave, because it's scalar.
And now we have done the
electron wave Schrodinger
equation before.
2m, d plus psi, I said, let me
think about the one electron,
1d dx squared plus u minus e.
This is the steady-state part.
u minus E, u is the potential,
E is the electron energy.
And of course, there is
a time-dependent part.
Remember, the time
dependent part
is just the exponential
mass i omega t, where
this omega equals e over h-bar.
That's the [INAUDIBLE]
correlation.
And for this wave,
we solve the before.
It's a simple second order
differential equation
with a constant coefficient.
So we solve this before, and
then let me write it down.
The general waveform--
if I combine
the time and the
space-dependent all together,
that looks more like a wave.
Plane wave i omega t minus
kx plus B e minus i omega t
plus kx.
I have two solutions.
That's what's we
read and done before.
Now you can tell me,
the first solution
is a wave propagating
in which direction?
Positive x.
Second wave is a
negative x direction.
Those are the two
counterpropagating waves.
And it's a superposition
of the two waves.
Now I'm going to look at the--
if I deposit the film
with the interface.
So this interface,
I look at the 1d.
So forget about the,
say, yz direction.
And so 1d interface, this
is one side of the film.
This is the other
side of the film.
And this is a typically-- if you
put two different semiconductor
together, and here is
conduction band EC1.
Here is conduction band EC2.
So EC1, EC2.
And the interface,
there's a discontinuity
of the energy of the electrons.
And the difference
here is u, or delta.
Different places have
different symbols.
And this is typically
called a heterojunction.
When I put two different
semiconductors together
at the interface, there's
a potential barrier.
You trigger potential barrier.
And the detail is more
complicated than I drew.
I drew a sharp one, and
in fact, the electron here
is not stable.
It's going to fall into here.
So it's not going to be as
flat as I'm drawing here.
Here's a very simple
approximation.
OK.
And now I have an
electron wave comes in,
so I can take a form
of the incident wave.
And if this is my x
direction, at the interface
there will be reflection.
The wave will go back.
On the other side, there
could be transmission.
The wave can go over
the barrier, continue.
So I have reflection,
I have transmission.
I want to find out
how much reflected,
how much transmitted.
OK.
So here, you can use
the plane wave solution.
For media one, let me take
this u as a reference.
This zero here is--
say, electron here
experiences a difference
between 0 and magnitude u.
So because of this, my k
in each region-- you see,
in region, let's say here is my
zero, origin of my coordinate.
And you can always
take your origin,
but typically, it's much
easier if you set the origin
at the interface.
At least at the first interface.
If you have
multi-layers you have
to continue because there's
distance from the 0.
So you count that distance.
So if I put this
one at zero, I have
an incident wave plus i. i,
right, this is the incident.
And has an amplitude a, and
going to the right-hand side--
so exponential minus
i omega t minus k1x,
because this is region one.
And this is region two.
My k is different because here,
my k, if you look at this,
is 2m E minus u divided
by h-bar squared.
You combine this together and
reverse the sign, E minus u.
Now they're u minus E. OK.
So in this region, u equals
0, so whatever energy,
E, of the electron
minus potential zero,
so that's the waveform,
the wave vector of k1.
And they reflect it
here beside this one.
This is reflective wave.
You can see the reflected
wave is going backwards.
My coefficient is on B e.
I say, I want to find
out the reflection, A,
and the B relation.
My transmitted wave
in region two--
so if I write down the
transmitted a wave is
exponential, again,
it's forward propagating
into positive x
direction, right?
So it's the same minus i
omega t minus k2x, not kyx.
And this k2, you can say is
2mE minus u now, h squared.
And the k1 is just--
u is zero, so it's 2m.
E is the energy of the electron.
2mE over h squared.
So this is the
difference of this waves.
Here in region
one, they incident
reflected the differ only by
here is plus, here is minus.
Coefficients, of
course, are different.
And transmitted wave in
region two, it's coefficient
is different, wave
vector is different.
Two difference.
So I want to find that
relation between one and two.
And to find those
relations, I have
to use a continue the
interface condition.
At the interface, the wave
function is continuous,
the derivative of the wave
function is continuous.
So the wave function, so
it's not just one wave
function when it's
a wave function.
It's all the waves.
You add them all together.
You add the waves together,
and so either the x equals 0.
What I have is a
psi i plus psi r.
On the left hand side, I have
two waves incident reflected.
x equal to zero equals psi t.
x is equal to zero.
What I get?
So the incident is a, x is equal
to zero, so k1x, that's zero.
Minus i omega t shares the same.
Omega is the energy
of the particle.
E divided by h is the
same on both sides.
So when you go, the wave go from
one media into the other media,
the frequency doesn't change.
OK.
And so what I have here is
really A plus B equals C. No?
Because the E minus i
omega t, E minus i omega t,
and psi t is E minus i omega t.
That all cancels.
X equals zero, so I have that.
My second condition
is a derivative.
So it's a total derivative
of all the waves,
and because the
summations, I put each one.
So I first take a derivative.
You have to be careful.
You first take the derivative,
you set it equal to zero.
And this equals derivative
x equal to zero.
So if you take a derivative--
so you say, with respect
to x, so this is ik.
Negative, negative.
So I have positive ik1a--
that's the first term.
That's the incident.
Reflected is B. And here
is mass i times plus k.
So I have a sign change
after I take the derivative,
so A must be equal
to ik2 times C.
So that's the application of
the two boundary condition.
Yes, Ross?
AUDIENCE: If there were to
be any different refractive
indices, would the frequency
change as the wave flows
through, or just the--
GANG CHEN: No, the
frequency doesn't change.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
GANG CHEN: Right.
When you have light go from
one media into another media,
the frequency does not change.
The wavelengths change.
So k is my--
remember, hk gives me momentum.
P equals hk or say, h-bar or
lambda give me the momentum.
So here is my two conditions.
And I want to find
the ratio because I
want to find transmission C
over A, reflection is B over A.
So to your question, I
want to find the ratio,
I can find those ratios.
And the ratio I have is--
so based on this, I have C
over A is 2k1, k1 plus k2.
And B over A is k1
minus k2, k1 plus k2.
So those are my solutions
for the coefficients
for the transmitted
wave and reflected wave
relative to the incident wave.
But what does this
coefficient really--
doesn't mean anything yet,
because we said before,
the wave function is not
a measurable quantity.
And quantum is the psi
times psi complex conjugate.
That gives the particles.
And the particle
flux in quantum,
the flux of the particle,
we give this expression
before, it's in the vector form
is i h-bar 2m and psi complex
conjugate for gradient of psi,
and psi complex conjugate times
gradient of psi.
So that's the particle flux.
And another way to write
this if you use a shorthand,
this is the real
part of i h-bar and m
psi complex conjugate
of our gradient.
Because this one is a complex
conjugate of this one,
so the difference overall
is a real part of this.
OK.
And now I'm going to
plug in, because I
want to say what's
my, for example,
if I have my incident,
if psi is my psi i,
you say psi i is a exponential
minus i omega t minus kx.
OK, so let's substitute that in.
So in this case,
the incident flux
is a real part of i h-bar m.
Psi is a exponential
minus i omega t minus k1x.
That's the incident.
So the derivative is d psi--
I first take complex conjugate,
and then I take the derivative.
And complex conjugate, this one
one because plus, because i.
Minus i becomes plus i.
And the k1, I'm going
to take a more uniform--
I say it's complex because
omega is the frequency.
With vector, I'm
going to also say
it could be real and
imaginary or complex number.
I treat it.
So in that case, if
I take a derivative,
I should have plussed--
that's i-- and this is times
mass complex conjugate k1
and exponential plus
omega t minus k1x.
And right.
So I have a A. I
should have a A. Here.
A complex conjugate.
OK.
And minus i omega t
plus i omega t cancel.
Time is not there.
And i kyx plus i kyx--
oh, here it should be
complex conjugate in general,
because I first take the complex
conjugate of this function.
And so in general,
this one may not
be zero, because this k1
and plus complex conjugate,
they may not cancel if
it's a imaginary number.
For my case here,
because in region one,
u is zero so this one is real.
Doesn't matter.
And also, the x equals zero.
This also goes out.
So at the end is j--
I list, I can say
either x equals zero.
You can say this is a A squared.
A times the A complex conjugate.
i times the i is negative 1.
Another negative, so
that's a positive.
So I really have this i.
This i cancel.
I have A, m, h, and k1.
So J1 equals hm,
and k1, A squared.
OK.
So this is my particle flux.
Incident, the flux.
And similarly, the
reflective flux,
if you substitute that in, it's
the same as hk1m B squared.
But the transmitted flux,
I have to be careful.
The reason I have
to be careful is
you can say my solution,
if energy is less than u,
k2 is imaginary.
So in that case, I have to be
really caring that real part
of k2 complex conjugate.
Because this is a
complex conjugate
k2 and the real part of that.
That's where I
have to be careful.
OK.
So based on this, I would
define the reflectance
and transmittance.
Sometimes I use reflectivity,
sometimes I use reflectance.
And the difference is--
some people, most people
don't distinguish it--
reflectivity is
more intrinsic, so
if you have a most ideal case.
That's an intrinsic
surface property.
And reflectance is extrinsic.
If your surface become
changed or rough,
well, then there's
a different value.
So this is a more rigorous
way of calling it,
but most of the time,
people don't care.
So reflectivity for
here, [INAUDIBLE]
is jr divided by ji.
And because k1 console in
the same media, so reflected,
transmitted, so you really just
have is B square over A square.
And B square over A square,
if you see B over A.
So I have k1 minus k2,
and k1 plus k2 squared.
So that's the reflectance at the
interface for a particle wave
due to quantum reflection.
And transmittance,
or transmitivity.
And there's also transmittance.
And in the transmittance, I
use tao equals Jt over Ji.
And here, it's different
because the j transmittance
is a real part of k2
complex conjugate,
or ky is real, anyway.
And here, I have C
squared over A squared.
And this is a real power of
k2, complex conjugate k1.
And C squared over A squared,
you can say it is k1 plus k2,
and 2k1 squared.
That's my transmittance.
OK.
Now because I carry
this real power,
I should really look
at a different scenario
when energy is larger than u.
If energy is larger than u,
k2, if you look at the k2
is 2mE minus u.
That's real.
The energy of the electron is
larger than the barrier height.
That's real.
And in that case,
Re also is, I can--
forget about this.
You can see this becomes a 4.
k1 times k2 divided
by k1 plus k2 squared.
OK.
So in this case, I
have tao is not zero.
But say R is not one.
I have quantum reflection.
Even through electron--
when you normally
think of electron as a particle
when it comes to an interface,
it has a reflection.
Even if its energy is higher
than the barrier height.
So now you just say, next time
you throw a ball over a wall,
there's a finite probability
it'll bounce back, even if you
threw it higher than the wall.
It's a quantum wall, right?
And so that's your first case.
And your second case
is E less than u.
Right E is less than u.
If you look here,
your k2 is imaginary.
k2 is imaginary, and the
real part, that's zero.
So if the energy
of the electron is
less than the barrier height of
u, your transmittance is zero,
and your reflectance, if you
plug it in here, this is real,
this is imaginary, this is
real, this is imaginary.
The modulus is one.
So reflectance is 1.
So the particle
is all reflected.
That's expected, right?
You threw a ball below
the wall, the particle--
the ball bounced back.
But there is still
something special.
You look at the other
side of the wall,
there is a finite
wave of the ball.
Why?
That's because if you look
at the transmittance--
so also the
transmittance, there is
no real particle go through
the wall, the barrier,
but the wave is not zero
because here, this is my wave.
Psi t minus i omega t.
k2 is imaginary, right?
k2 is imaginary, so imaginary
times imaginary, real.
It's a negative real, so it's
a negative exponential decay
function.
So in this case, what I have
is this is a a ball coming in,
the particle comes
in, and there is
a fan at the wave on the
other side of the interface.
The time-- the average
speaking, there's
no particle going in
to the other side,
but the wave function is
now zero on the other side.
And this wave is called
everlasting wave.
Evanescent.
And now what's the
magnitude of those?
So if you look at your decay
of this evanescent wave,
if you look at the decay
of evanescent wave,
it's really the magnitude of
E minus u 2m h-bar squared.
That's the square root.
This is really the magnitude.
So what I have here,
the magnitude of k
is 2m real E minus
u and h-bar squared.
That's the k2.
That's the decay.
Or u minus E.
So if I look at the
electron u minus E.
Let's say we take one
electron volt. So the energy--
so the order of magnitude is 2
times 9.1 10 to the minus 31.
And electron volts, one electron
volt is 1.6 10 to the minus 19.
And h-bar squared, h-bar is
1 10 to the minus 34, so 68.
So this one is 31.
19 gives me 50.
And this gives me
68, so that's 18.
18 square root is of the order
of 9, and the rest is OK here.
Maybe I have five.
Order of line inverse meter.
OK.
So that's the magnitude
of this wave extent
if it's an electron
into the other side.
It's of the order inverse
of that gives me what?
2 angstroms, right?
So it's an evanescent
and rapidly decaying--
exponentially rapidly decaying
wave on the other side.
So who cares 2 angstroms, right?
Then let me tell a story.
So there was this guy.
He just finished his PhD
and went to a job interview
at IBM Zurich.
And his name is Binnig.
And the interviewer
asked him, said
they want to measure
the surface roughness
to very high precision, asking
him whether he had the ideas
or not.
And he thought about
this, and came up
with the idea that's
using a metal tip,
and this is a metal surface.
And he put a bias,
so vacuum here.
There's an energy level.
You read the Einstein
work function.
Maybe you didn't read the--
you read the wave nature,
the particle nature of light.
But say there is a few
electron volts gap here,
the barrier vacuum.
Work function of metal.
So here is a few electron volts.
And he say, if you
bias it with a voltage,
the electron exponential decay.
But once they meet the outer
metal, become alive again.
We'll talk about that.
That's autonomy of
this evanescent wave.
And it's very sensitive
to atomic scale bumpiness,
because this is
angstrom-level exponential.
So with that, you can measure--
that's the principle of
scanning tunneling microscope.
You really can measure
the electron wave function
on the surface.
So you can actually
image the atoms.
And so he got a
Nobel Prize for that.
OK.
Hopefully you'll get
a chance when you
have an interview like that.
You have to think, you
have to be able to come up
with the idea, right?
So that's the quantum work.
It's going up a hill.
Now you reverse it.
You say, "what if my electron
is going backwards from here
to here?"
Is there a reflection.
You look at the derivation,
there's no difference.
Even if you go downhill,
even if you not go barrier,
you go a step down, you
still have a reflection.
You have discontinuity.
In potential, you
have reflection there.
So this is, in fact, this
is a Lomer incidence.
And when you consider
actually electrical interface
resistance, for example,
electrons can actually
come to an interface.
Not just Lomer, it can
come all directions.
And you should be able
to sit there and do
any angle in incidents.
in fact, I check a lot of
electrical engineering book.
Nobody even did that.
I was surprised.
OK, if you're an electrical
engineer, you should do this.
So this is for electron wave.
And now let's go, we
say this is scalar wave.
It's the easiest.
And let's go to
more complicated.
And let's look at
the vector wave.
And vector wave, the least
complicated vector wave
is the electromagnetic wave.
EM waves.
That's probably the big leap
from a Schrodinger equation,
which is a scalar
equation, which
is by no means easy to solve.
We got a model of our electrons.
They're actually not a good
tool to solve that right now.
Even if you have two
or three electrons,
their mutual interaction
becomes very difficult to solve.
And that's many-body problem.
But say, let's go to EM waves.
And for that, you have to
go to Maxwell equations.
And either you forgot it
or you heard about it.
So let's rewrite the
Maxwell equations.
And we have four equations.
E cross H minus time derivative.
They cross E, and cross H
is D. Dt plus the current.
And we have then the divergence
of the displacement field
equals the charge density.
And the diverging magnetic
induction is zero.
And just to review,
this is essentially
what the first equations say.
If you change your
magnetic field,
you have a general
electric field.
Then secondly, if you pass
a current through a coil,
you generate a magnetic field.
And this is the Faraday
law, this is more like
an Ampére's law.
Some of the high
school experiment.
And Maxwell only
add the one term,
and he got all the credit.
OK.
So what we have here, E
is the electric field.
The electric field
is the gradient
of electrostatic potential.
And so the unit is
volt over meter.
And H is a magnetic
field, and sometimes I
don't remember the unit, so
I go back to think of this.
Current density I know.
Current density here
is m per meter squared.
So here is the u--
so times 1 meter,
that gives me magnetic
field as m per meter.
So magnetic field
is m per meter.
And D is the electrical
displacement.
Displacement.
And what it means is that
if you have a material,
you have atoms.
Atoms has electrons,
ions, right?
If you have an electric
field comes in,
you know that they
will get polarized.
Positive charge has a force
along the field direction.
Negative charge,
opposite field direction.
So that means they
will have a dipole.
So you have, in this case,
you have more like a dipole.
Here is a positive,
here is a negative.
OK.
So D is the polarization
per unit volume,
dipole moment per unit volume,
and plus the-- if you have
original field comes in,
converting into the same unit--
so that's a epsilon zero.
That's a vacuum.
Plus the polarization per
unit, the dipole moment
per unit volume.
So dipole moment is
the charge transmitter,
and per unit volume is
cubic, so the unit here
is a coulomb per meter squared.
And from coulomb
per meter square,
this is a coulomb
you find the epsilon zero.
That's the vacuum permittivity.
I always say "permeability,"
"permittivity."
Permittivity, epsilon zero
is 8.8 10 to the minus 12,
and here should be
coulomb epsilon here
is farad per meter.
OK.
So I have this one
is a farad per meter.
OK.
So I have the--
this is D here, the
displacement field.
I said that this is
the one external field
create a dipole, right?
This is real solid.
It's not that simple
because you have atom here,
you have another atom here.
You have adjacent atoms.
And not only are
they outside field,
but also the next
labor, the dipole
itself will affect
the atom itself.
So it's actually a summation
of all this effect.
And this one, this is
a non-movable charge.
This is the charge
attached to the atom.
That's dielectric.
So we sometimes
write the epsilon.
Epsilon r times E. Well,
this combined together
gives me another epsilon.
That's a dielectric
function of the material.
It's not a constant.
Sometimes we call it
dielectric constant.
It's not a constant.
It's a function of wave lengths.
It's a function of frequency.
OK.
So that's the displacement.
And similarly,
[INAUDIBLE] induction,
B, you can write it as a
epsilon vacuum, a mu vacuum,
mu r times H. This is
just like we're writing
to the displacement field.
It's the electric field times
the dielectric constant.
And here is the
vacuum permittivity,
the relative to vacuum.
Most materials are at
high visible wavelengths
or high frequency.
This one is about one.
It doesn't have
magnetic response.
Most materials.
At a low frequency,
you have magnet.
But say high frequency,
most material
don't have the
magnetic response.
And in fact, that was
the basis of an invention
made by Professor [INAUDIBLE].
He was trying to think about
how do you get a powerless--
wireless, cordless
power transfer.
And the problem is if you
want to beam a lot of power
through this space
we'll all be cooked.
We have dielectric
response, right?
Microwave, you heat it up.
But say because materials
at a high frequency
don't have magnetic
response, so you
thought about using a magnetic
field to deliver the power.
So we have the start up.
Try and commercialize that.
OK.
So that's the basic equations.
And a few more comments.
The relation between current--
that's a real current,
a free electron.
The current flow.
And current, of course, is
related to electric field
through if you have a conductor
or semiconductor, that's
the Ohm's law.
So j equals electric
conductivity.
That's Ohm's law.
Electric conductivity is sigma.
And here, the unit is
inverse ohm, centimeter.
Right?
Ohm, centimeter.
Yeah.
Inverse.
No.
It should be inverse.
So inverse ohm is also same
m per meter, different units.
If you don't use it often,
it's very confusing.
OK.
So we have all these quantities.
And further, what
is the epsilon,
let's say, the charge density.
OK.
And this charge density
is the lab charge
per unit volume in the material.
OK, so if you have
a semiconductor,
you know, semiconductor you
can have a positive donor, say,
if you put a phosphor there.
OK, so let's say put
that phosphor atom
in silicon and phosphor atom.
Lose the electron.
So the atom itself is immobile,
electron becomes immobile.
So what do you need is
this is a positive charge.
You also have
electronegative charge.
You add them all together,
that's per unit volume.
How much charge you have?
So these are the set
of equations describing
the electromagnetic waves.
And now we can see why.
Let's do a few math operation
just to get familiar with it.
You have seen them.
So if I look at this, I
will first eliminate a--
because the B right here,
I can write as a mu h.
Mu zero times mu r is mu.
And permittivity.
And so B equals mu h.
So I used the first one.
I get the first equation, delta
across E equals mass D mu h Dt.
That's the first equation.
And the second equation,
I have delta across H,
E across D, Dt,
and epsilon times
E. This is a dielectric
function, which
is epsilon zero times epsilon
r, the displacement field
plus sigma times E.
Those are the-- if I
use considered relations
and eliminate B and D,
I got the equation here.
And let me first
to drop this term.
Let's consider a dielectric.
There's no free charge
in the material,
so electrical
conductivity is zero.
With that I can plug
this H into here,
and I take a time
derivative on both sides,
and then I gather D, H. So
this is assuming mu and epsilon
are independent of time.
And if it depends on time,
you have to be careful.
[PHONE RINGING]
That's not mine, right?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
GANG CHEN: Oh, OK.
So if I eliminate--
if I take this epsilon mu out,
I'll be independent of time.
And sometimes you
have to be careful,
because when you do those kind
of mathematical operations,
you make assumptions, you may
lose the big opportunities, OK?
And this is the
electromagnetic field.
There are a lot of
new concepts that
is all based on going back
to the original equation
and relook at
them, and say are--
where are the
approximations made?
You were reading Yablonovitch
chapter, essay, paper
on photonic crystal, right?
And his photonic
crystal is really--
that's the concept in that case,
the epsilon, which we typically
take as uniform,
but he was really
taking this uniform epsilon
as a periodic function.
So he put the epsilon
as a periodic function,
and that's like a periodic
potential for atoms.
If you think about that when we
saw the band gap of electrons
for Schrodinger equation,
that come from the fact
that the potential for
electrons is periodic.
Maxwell's equation itself,
there is no potential here.
He put this one
epsilon as a constant,
and then he was really
using the analogy.
And in fact, I spent--
on day, I was in Berlin.
We both of us were
wandering in the city.
So I was talking to him.
He said that when he
conceived the concept
of photonic crystal,
he wrote the paper.
So photonic crystal.
What is-- a photonic crystal is
basically periodic arrangement
of whatever--
glass beads.
You can think about that, right?
And if you look at the
evolution, in ball crystal,
we have band gap.
And in the '70s,
there is this concept
of a superlattice,
quantum wells.
You read, again,
[INAUDIBLE] paper.
And that's put in multi
layers of thin films.
That makes the one dimension.
You got the artificial.
This is where we draw the
potential, purely potential.
That's the [INAUDIBLE] and
panning model we talked before,
but it's artificial material.
So you go from three dimensional
crystal purely potential to 1D,
and that's a big jump
in concept because
of the artificial
quantum structures.
And on the other hand, in
optics, you have the latter.
Over a hundred years, people
know how to do coding.
People have been
doing, refining optics
to code multilayer films.
Some of this is purely--
I will say anti-reflection or
purely reflecting the purpose.
And so the reason, so you have
those multilayer, thin film
coatings, which is typically
of the order of quarter
wavelengths.
And you can code this so that
it's complete reflection.
What is a complete reflection?
It is the wave function
of electromagnetic wave
zero inside.
That's forbidden.
There's a band gap in 1D.
So what I will always propose
as a photonic crystal,
is how to make
this back into 3D.
What laser has is
electron photons in 3D,
and say, researchers, we have
created this 1D structure.
So that's what you see is
the opposite direction going.
And here is trying to make
photonic analogy of some field
to 3D.
OK.
So he said that when
he wrote the paper,
you go to read his paper
and there's no math inside.
It was just a concept.
And he submitted a paper.
And he knows who he
wants to be reviewer.
And his friend
said, do you really
want to publish this paper?
This is a really--
it doesn't look like a paper.
He said, it doesn't matter.
Just publish it.
So that's what you read.
It's the beginning of a new
field, photonic crystal.
OK.
So epsilon is a function of r.
Periodic, right?
And epsilon could also
be a function of time.
In fact, I was doing some--
when I did my
graduate school study,
I never came up with big ideas,
but once I was writing down
the loads, I said, OK,
because I was doing some stuff
during the optical, say
the [INAUDIBLE] laser
material interaction.
During that process,
the epsilon wall
changed as a function
of temperature,
and temperature changed
as a function of time,
so I have to keep that there.
I wrote all those equations.
And a few years later,
my friend asked me,
I said, actually,
it's in my notes.
But it never got anywhere.
So one story.
But anyway, let's continue here.
I have two equations.
I drop this.
I'm going to name that--
I say mu epsilon constant.
And I'm going to
then put it out.
And I can eliminate H.
And what I have here
then is the equation.
So if I eliminate H, I have
a delta across E over a mu.
And here, I have epsilon.
I start to get a wave equation.
And you can use the
vector operation
to rewrite this into--
if you use a vector
relation, you will get--
actually, there is a
negative sign in the front.
And delta epsilon square,
mu epsilon, DE, Dt square.
And if I continue to carry that,
it will be mu sigma DE, Dt.
OK.
This is the one.
I carry the metal term,
the conductivity term.
If I don't, I have a
pure wave equation.
If I drop this, you can say
this is a wave equation.
Second order in space,
second order in time,
unlike the Schrodinger
equation, which
is the first order in time,
but has an imaginary number
in the front.
Now I have a real wave equation.
It's the second order
in both space and time.
So this is the Maxwell equation.
And if you look at the typical
wave solution, plane wave,
epsilon is a function of r
and t, and this is a vector,
so that's the polarization
direction, the electrical field
direction, and this is
the propagation direction,
omega t minus k dot r.
So this is a plane
wave expression.
We talked before.
And the assumption back
into here, you will say,
is satisfying the wave equation.
And in fact, if you do it,
if you substitute it back,
say the left hand side is
the second order derivative
in space, so I'll get k squared.
So I will get k dot k.
And the right hand side, I
will get a mu omega squared.
This is time.
And epsilon plus
i sigma and omega.
This is this term combined
with the first term.
And the rest, i omega
t, this term cancel,
the phase factor all cancel.
OK.
And this way, I can
write the expression as,
because omega squared, so I have
mu epsilon tilde omega squared.
The wave vector is
proportional to omega.
For a wave in free space,
this is epsilon zero, mu zero.
Free space.
And this is what the triumph
of electromagnetic wave,
because Maxwell's equation
predicted the speed of light.
OK.
Because when you do this,
you get the magnitude,
k squared equals
omega divided by--
here, I do the square
root of epsilon tilde, mu.
And this one, we
can write it into--
so I can write it k,
the magnitude of--
this is not square.
The magnitude.
So the magnitude of k
equals omega times C. Ck.
Omega equals Ck.
That's the dispersion.
And C is square root of
epsilon tilde and mu.
And typically, I would
define refractive index
as the speed of light in vacuum
divided by speed of light
in the medium.
And the speed of light in
vacuum, this is epsilon 0,
mu zero, and it's approximated
because most high frequency
magnetic response is 1.
So this is epsilon
tilde over epsilon 0.
And this one is epsilon r.
So even for metals,
very often we tabulate.
We don't tabulate
these two separately.
We just tabulate them
together into epsilon r,
the relative
dielectric constant.
OK so there are a few
interesting stories here again.
OK.
You take a positive square
root going from here to here.
You take a square root, and then
say that's a natural solution.
And if you go to look at
your Maxwell equation,
it turns out that this wave,
it's a right-hand wave.
So say this is
epsilon E direction,
electric field direction.
It's a transverse wave.
This is what the
equation tells you.
Go, you check.
It's a transverse
wave, so electric field
will be perpendicular
to a magnetic field,
will be perpendicular to k,
the wave vector direction,
k, the wave propagation
there, right?
That's why it's a
transverse wave.
So now the only transverse
wave is also a right-hand wave.
What the right
hand mean is if you
recall when you learned
those, say, as E across h
goes to the wave
propagation direction.
So there's a right-hand
side, your E direction.
You grab to the h
direction then some point
to do the k direction.
OK.
So it's a right-hand wave.
It's a transverse wave.
Except I say we ignore
the possibility of when
you take this k square
root, it could be a negative
also, root solution.
Negative solution
typically are ruled out,
but if when epsilon and mu could
be negative, when both of them
could be negative, it
turns out that you go back
to check the equation again, you
have to take a negative root.
So this effect was
predicted in 1950s
by Russian scientist
[INAUDIBLE]..
And his paper was
soon forgotten.
OK.
By the '90s, people start
to pay attention to it.
First, they are
natural materials
with the epsilon negative.
It just doesn't have
natural materials with mu
equals negative.
Why the natural material
could have epsilon negative?
Epsilon, remember,
is the response
of the material-- oh,
I think I erased it.
When you have electric field,
the material will polarize.
If it's an electron,
for example, and then
when you have an external
wave comes in oscillating,
the electron creates a
resistance, say, direction
and field.
And if that field is
larger than the incident,
you get the negative
direction displacement.
So the epsilon becomes negative.
But there's no material
with the mu negative.
Then, say, in
'90s, people design
this artificial resonator
structure that created,
generated a, say,
artificial magnetic.
So you basically create
a loop with a gap.
And when the electric current
oscillate in this loop,
they generate magnetic field.
And when you make
them very small,
the magnetic field could
be very, very fast.
Make it smaller.
And if you bring
both epsilon and mu
negative within the
same frequency range,
you have to go to take
that negative root.
So become a
left-handed material.
So E across h, k
goes the other way.
So this is a k go this way,
but energy go this way.
A lot of confusion
at the beginning,
because whether this
possible or not, um.
If you check the
literature, this is a quote,
"metamaterial."
OK.
It's not "metal" materials.
M-A, not M-E, OK?
And there's an
interesting story,
many interesting
stories, but some people
say "metal materials."
So we study metals, but
it's not a metal material.
It's a meta.
And it's really artificially
designed material,
so it has strange properties.
And while this is the
first achievement that
is a designed material
in microwave range,
so to prove that the
refractive index really should
be taking a negative value.
So that's a really--
later on, you will say,
it's pretty strange
because when we
think about optical
light refraction,
this is the refraction.
Snell law.
We'll talk next the Snell law.
But when the A is
negative, the refraction
actually happens this way.
And it's pretty weird.
So it's still a
very active field.
And you heard Harry Potter
story, the cloaking?
Huh?
Right?
So in that case,
what happens is it
could be solution
of Maxwell equation.
Come seeing here,
you have an object.
And this actually would be
easier for fluid mechanics,
if you look at fluid
mechanics, right?
And in small [INAUDIBLE]
laminar flow, go this way.
So what it means, the Maxwell
solution like this means
is even if you have an
object here if you're away,
you don't see far away.
There's no scattered light.
So what do you see?
The light goes around,
but say you look at it,
it's just like the
object doesn't exist.
That's what they say some
of the strange effect
of those metamaterials.
OK.
And I think, say, I'll stop
here, but let's look at the--
now you can see a lot
of interesting stuff.
It's a lot longer.
So if you go to check, I
said this at the beginning.
There are a lot of
people, there are
papers that say there's
no negative refraction.
They say basically this
is a little bit confusing
because the energy
propagating moving forward
and information is
propagating backwards.
Typically, people like
to associate wave vector
to information.
And there's a lot of
debate in literature.
But now, I think the
debate is all gone.
And it's very active, in fact.
So I just mentioned that
epsilon could be negative.
When epsilon negative,
there is also--
it turns out that the--
again, all this we're going
to talk more next lecture.
There is a surface wave.
We just said the
evanescent wave is
exponential decay on one side.
We just saw the electronic
evanescent wave.
You have photon evanescent wave.
But say this, when
epsilon is negative,
you could have a surface wave
that decays on both sides,
doesn't exist far away
from the interface,
so it's only confined
to the surface.
And that's the surface plasmon,
and these are the electron.
So let's say-- let me
just do a feel for time.
No, I'll go to this image.
OK, so though you can
say that this is a really
periodic structure in 3D or 2D.
Originally, it's like a film
the size of a cell, right?
In fact, I was at the UCLA
[INAUDIBLE],, which was UCLA--
I remember once I attended
a student thesis meeting,
and there was another
professor just saying,
"there's no photonic crystal.
It's just a Bragg reflector."
Bragg reflector is
the 1D structure.
People call it Bragg reflector.
Because 3D gives you a
different name and suddenly,
open up your imagination.
And so people started looking
at the photonic semiconductor
where you have a gap, and you
can dope your photonic crystal.
And what does that mean?
And so you can say
some of those is
you can guide the
light in the structures
and bending 90 degree.
And normally, optical
fiber, you can't do that,
and you have to make a slow
turn if you use optical fibers.
But if you use this
kind of structure,
you can have a more
complicated, say, light path
and metamaterials.
And this was the
first experiment
where they used the split run.
In fact, it's 2D, so they show
that this kind of structure.
And it could have a negative
epsilon and a negative mu
at the same frequency range.
And it was a pretty
large structure.
And they did the
microwave experiment,
and showed light can
indeed go the wrong way.
That's what people say, might
bend the wrong way normally,
against intuition.
And after that, there
are a lot of structures.
And let's look at the cloaking.
Well, this is not--
people are not able
to do that yet.
That's a different
way of doing it.
But that's what I was
explaining, right?
If your light doesn't
get scattering
into other directions, so
essentially if you're away
from it, you don't
look at it, there's
no reflection signal
you can detect.
OK.
And So story is, don't
miss the details, OK?
Some have a tiny effect, but
they could be a big story.